and joining us now with reaction RNC
chair Ronnie McDaniel great to see you
we've talked through this entire process
on radio and in person about this and a
major achievement the president gets a
major legislative win and the RNC now as
I just said dad do you guys have to take
it to the streets where do you begin
well it is a historic day it's a great
Christmas present and President Trump
led the way you know I think about a
year ago when he was coming to my state
of Michigan and traveling this country
and recognizing that wages were stagnant
that people were suffering and now today
he has said we are fighting for you we
are gonna give the middle class a huge
tax cut we are gonna make your paychecks
bigger we're gonna increase jobs we're
gonna grow our economy we're gonna fight
for the American people so at the
Republican Party we're gonna keep
hammering home the great accomplishments
of this president and Senator McConnell
and and speaker Ryan and then we're
gonna remind them that the Democrats
were nowhere to be found in fact joe
Manchin went home and he saw a big
banner that said remember in November
we're gonna make sure they remember in
November that no Democrats supported
middle-class tax cuts and helping the
American people let's talk about the
major driver of the economy and that is
the corporate side of this and I'm not
talking about the mega corporations s
corpse L corpse ll PS small businesses
the individual truckers out there they
call every day they ask what does this
mean to me what does it mean to them the
people that are in that 50 to $75,000
income level but they have a
pass-through they have a business what
does it mean to them well it means
they're gonna take more money home and
it's and it's a two-fold twofold in that
we've cut so many regulations the
president focused on that at the at the
first three months of his administration
cutting regulations and that is so
important to the small business owner
because they were so constricted by
these cumbersome regulations that were
preventing them from growing and being
able to expand their businesses so that
and then with the tax cuts they're gonna
take more money home they're gonna be
able to invest in their businesses
they're also going to be able to help
their families this is a great day for
small businesses for like you said those
truck drivers people across the country
are gonna benefit and that's
exactly who president Trump targeted
with this huge tax reform bill all right
and then we brought it up a little while
ago or on it I gotta tell you he's got a
good point can the Republicans write a
30-second ad that lays out for the
American people what this means what
does that ad say to the American people
in 30 seconds well Republicans are
putting the American people first and we
are increasing their paychecks we're
gonna focus on creating more jobs we're
gonna increase wages and we're gonna
grow this economy and we are gonna make
America a better place for all Americans
and we have delivered at every turn this
year and we're just gonna keep doing it
so give us the majority in 2018 all
right now let's talk about some other
things I like to cover the things that
aren't always there today is a big day
with tax cuts great Christmas present
for Americans but what about other
things regulatory reform we've got
immigration on the table to deal with
daca we've got so many issues and
there's been a divide at points in the
Republican Party is a party going to
come together now that the president has
a head of steam and with the help of the
RNC go out and do these things border
security there's words out the
president's going to the border to look
at these walls well so much has been
accomplished in this year as we look at
the Year in Review we look at the
judicial appointments you look at neo
corset you look at our veterans
Accountability Act you looked at our
increased military spending and
deregulation and tax cuts we're just
going to keep doing that the president
has signaled that he wants to tackle
infrastructure next year that's
something that should bring bipartisan
support you know there's a lot in the
accomplishment column for Republicans
what if Democrats done this year what
have they accomplished nothing resist
and obstruct and fighting this president
at every turn even if it's in the best
interest of their constituents is not a
message that they're going to be able to
run on in 2018 this tax bill has shown
that we can come together as a party we
can govern as a party we have a
president who is leading the way and
we're going to continue fighting for the
American people are handed out to
Democrats we want them to come across
the aisle and work with us but if
they're not going to we're going to get
it done well are they really going to
come across the aisle as we wrap this up
because we've heard Chuck Schumer say
that Republicans are going to rue the
day when they do this Nancy Pelosi this
is the worst thing this is Armageddon
I'm paraphrasing you know the words that
are being used and they're not reading
the bills nothing new for Democrats but
are they really going to come to the
table well there's some senators who I
think are going to be looking at 2018
joe Manchin Heidi Heitkamp Joe Donnelly
John tester sherrod Brown these these
senators in these these red states were
President Trump one they want the photo
op with the president they want to show
that there PI partisan but so far they
are totally beholden to their leadership
Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi and when
voters go to the ballot booth next
November they're gonna ask what did my
senator do and we've got real
opportunities to pick up seats if they
can't come across the aisle and work on
anything especially middle-class tax
cuts and infrastructure thanks Rhonda
and by the way great to see you have a
Merry Christmas to you and your family
you've worked very hard in the first
part of this term so good luck have a
great Christmas you deserve a break
Merry Christmas thank you David